David Boder: [In English] Chicago, November the 16th, 1950. This is spool 9-40. The...a short interview with a child, Esther Freilich, the daughter of Mrs. Frieda Freilich...of whom we have that long interview, reported in the book as, eh...”Mrs. Freich.” Boder.
David Boder: Now for a short statement...eh...Esther...Esther Frieden...was hat?
Esther Freilich: Freilich.
David Boder: Esther Freilich, whose mother has covered Spool 36, 37 and 38. Esther is 13 years old.
David Boder: [In German] Also, Esther, sag mal, [unverständlich] wie heisst du und wie alt bist du?
Esther Freilich: Ich, ich heiss Esther Freilich. Ich bin [unverständlich, auch schon?] dreizehn Jahr.
David Boder: Du bist [unverständlich]. Wenn war dein Geburtstag?
Esther Freilich: Im 11. März.
David Boder: Im 11. März warst du dreizehn Jahre alt.
Esther Freilich: Ja.
David Boder: Ja. Also, Esther, erzähl mir, äh, du warst mit deiner Mutter genommen worden wie viele Mal?
Esther Freilich: Oh, drei, vier Mal.
David Boder: Drei, vier Mal.
Esther Freilich: Ja.
David Boder: Äh, erzähl mir, wie war’s...wie war es in, in der Drancy. Warst du in der Drancy.
Esther Freilich: Ja. Ich war in der Drancy.
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Freilich: Ich komme in ein [unverständlich] um zweie bei Nacht. In [unverständlich] und machen wir im Kommissariat. Im, äh, Kommissariat machen bereit. Und nachher mal nehmen wir in Zug und wir fahren bis Drancy.
Esther Freilich: Wir gehen.
David Boder: Also, wer ist gekommen zu Hause, euch nehmen und wenn war es?
Esther Freilich: Die französische Poli, Police.
David Boder: Die Police ist gekommen. Um wieviel Uhr?
Esther Freilich: Zwei Uhr von Nacht.
David Boder: Um zwei Uhr bei Nacht.
Esther Freilich: Ja.
David Boder: Und was haben sie gesagt?
Esther Freilich: Sie haben mir gesagt, dass [unverständlich]. Wir sollen machen unsere Paketen, wo sie [unverständlich]. Wo [unverständlich]...
David Boder: [unverständlich]
Esther Freilich: Ja.
David Boder: Nun, und was für eine Paketen habt ihr gemacht?
Esther Freilich: Ähm, wir haben genehmt, was man gedacht, das Nötige.
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Freilich: Aber sie haben gesagt, man darf nicht [unverständlich]...
Esther Freilich: Weil, äh, [unverständlich]
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Freilich: Wir haben doch verstanden, wenn wir gegangen, haben wir genehmt, was man gedacht, hat gemeint, man darf...
David Boder: Hm, hm. Und wo ist der Vater gewesen? Wo ist der...
Esther Freilich: Unser Vater, er hat gearbeitet bei Nacht.
David Boder: Aha. Nun und wer ist gegangen denn, Ihre Mutter und wer noch?
Esther Freilich: Die Mutter, der Brother und ich.
David Boder: Ja, und du. Nun, und man hat dich genommen auf dem Kommissariat.
Esther Freilich: Ja. Auf dem Kommissariat hat man uns angeschaut den [unverständlich]
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Freilich: Die [unverständlich]
Esther Freilich: [Unverständlich]
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Freilich: Ich gegangen mit Mama, die war dann weg nach Drancy.
David Boder: Und der Bruder?
Esther Freilich: Mit dem Bruder.
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Freilich: Sind wegfahren nach Drancy.. Ich war ein großer [unverständlich]
Esther Freilich: Groß! Und...
David Boder: Ja, wie seit ihr gefahren nach Drancy?
Esther Freilich: Mit dem Autobus.
David Boder: Mit dem Autobus. Ja, nun?
Esther Freilich: Sind wir angekommen nach Drancy. Hat [unverständlich] auch genommen, die, durch die Gebot.
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Freilich: Und haben gewartet in eine, äh, eine große, äh, Haus. Und [unverständlich] alle Sachen.
Esther Freilich: Sie nimmt alles. Und [unverständlich], die Männ.., die Männer, da ham sie gesagt, die [unverständlich]
David Boder: Ja, und wo hat man genommen deinen Bruder?
Esther Freilich: Der Bruder?
David Boder: Mit den Männ...?
Esther Freilich: Ja, mit den Männern.
David Boder: Und du bist geblieben mit...
Esther Freilich: Mit der Mutter.
David Boder: Ja. Nun, erzähl mir, was ist dorten passiert?
Esther Freilich: Das war, dorten...da hab ich...[unverständlich]...hat gelegen ein Bett auf dem anderen
David Boder: Ja. Mit wem bist du geschlafen?
Esther Freilich: Mit der Mutter.
David Boder: Du hast geschlafen mit der Mutter.
Esther Freilich: Ja.
David Boder: Und was hat man euch zu essen gegeben?
Esther Freilich: Ich hab erst mit der Mutter...[unverständlich]...
David Boder: Hmm, ja, mit der Mutter bei [unverständlich]
Esther Freilich: Mit dabei war und [unverständlich] Kinder. Hat man dann [unverständlich] an das Rote Kreuz und [unverständlich, klingt wie „Aral“?] geschickt.
David Boder: Hmm.
Esther Freilich: Hat man, äh, Aral [?] geschickt, weil die Kinder krank sind. Die Kinder sind in ein großes Lager, mit alle Kinder sind ´gangen. Mit dem...gibt, gibt ein Kaffee, mit Müller...
David Boder: Hmm. Ja.
Esther Freilich: Und hat gegeben Brot...
David Boder: Ach so...
Esther Freilich: Und eine kleine [unverständlich, klingt wie „polnische“] Puppe.
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Freilich: Und, äh, dann hat, äh, deportiert.
Esther Freilich: Hat man gi...gibt, ein bisserl, äh, Meial [gemeint ist: „Mehl“] für die Kinder
David Boder: Ein bisschen Mehl
Esther Freilich: Ja.
David Boder: Für die deportierte Kinder?
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Freilich: Nu...
David Boder: Nun, und äh, was hat dir passiert denn?
Esther Freilich: Mir? Man hat, ja, äh, [unverständlich, klingt wie „arretiert“ oder „avertiert“]...
David Boder: Was denn [unverständlich]
Esther Freilich: Die Police. Hat extra [unverständlich] und hat dort ihr [unverständlich]
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Freilich: Stollwitz [?] Hat mir das rausgemacht.
David Boder: Hmm.
Esther Freilich: Und der Typ hat mir den rausgegangen, von Drancy hat man deportiert nach Deutschland.
David Boder: Wen? Die anderen Leute?
Esther Freilich: Ja.
David Boder: Und du und dein Bruder seid gegangen.
Esther Freilich: Ich mit dem Bruder, mit der, ah, ah, Mutter, mit anderen Familie sind wir rausgegangen und noch ein kleine Tier.
David Boder: Ja, warum seid ihr rausgegangen?
Esther Freilich: Weil mein Vater David da hat [unverständlich] gelernt.
David Boder: Aha.
Esther Freilich: Und während, während der, äh, Grippe hat gelacht außer [unverständlich], verstehst?
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Freilich: Oder?
David Boder: Nun? Und was noch willst du von erzählen?
Esther Freilich: Ich will dir erzählen, hat mich wegen [unverständlich] aus Paris. Hat mich [unverständlich] Ich bin [unverständlich, klingt wie „gewöhnt“]. Also, ich hab gesehen, die Kinder spielen in den Gassen.
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Freilich: [unverständlich] leid. Ich hab mich [unverständlich]
David Boder: Warum nicht?
Esther Freilich: Die Police hat nicht gelassen. In Deutschland verboten. Kinder [unverständlich] in dem Kino.
David Boder: Ja. Die jüdischen Kinder.
Esther Freilich: Ja, jüdische Kinder.
David Boder: Hast du getroffen, äh, [unverständlich]
Esther Freilich: [unverständlich]
David Boder: Die [klingt wie: „gelle Lake?“] hast du getroffen?
Esther Freilich: Ja. Ich hab auch...[klingt wie: Kopf]...ich hab noch...[klingt wie: „eine gelle Lake“]
David Boder: Ja, musst du mir nächstes Mal zeigen.
Esther Freilich: Ich wird das zeigen...[unverständlich] gehabt [unverständlich]
David Boder: Ja. Und, äh, man hat dir nicht gelassen spielen im Garten.
Esther Freilich: Nein, man hat nicht.
David Boder: Bist du gegangen zur Schule?
Esther Freilich: Nur die vier Tag. [unverständlich]...die letzte Moment hat mir nicht [unverständlich]. Ich hab [unverständlich] weil, äh, [unverständlich]...in die Schule [unverständlich]. Und mir, mir hat ja nicht gewusst, dass [unverständlich]...hat man mich herausgenehmt.
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Freilich: Verstehen Sie? Bin ich nicht gegangen.
David Boder: Aha. [unverständlich] Dort habt ihr gelebt? Wer wart ihr denn dort? Der Vater oder die Mutter?
Esther Freilich: Nein, ich war allein. Zwei Jahre ich gefahren allein.
David Boder: [Unverständlich] Zwei Jahre warst du allein?
Esther Freilich: Ohne wissen was meine Elteren...[unverständlich]
David Boder: Wieso? Wer hat die geschickt die da?
Esther Freilich: [unverständlich]
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Freilich: Hat sie ihr nicht gesagt, dass...sie kennt eine junge Frau.
Esther Freilich: [unverständlich] behaupten
David Boder: Ja, ja.
Esther Freilich: [unverständlich]
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Freilich: Ja, bin ich gefahren. Die Mutter, [unverständlich], ich ja nicht gewusst, was die Mutter denn gemacht...Ich hab gemeint, die Mutter sind schon lang nach Deutschland.
David Boder: Welche Mutter?
Esther Freilich: Meine Mutter.
David Boder: Wieso?
Esther Freilich: Weil ich hab nicht gewusst, was die Mutter...ich hab nicht gekonnt schreiben.
David Boder: Oh! Du hast nicht gekonnt schreiben!
Esther Freilich: Ja! Weil, äh, die Mutter hat mir geschrieben [unverständlich]...äh, ich hab geschrieben, also meine, äh, Briefe...
David Boder: Ja, ja.
Esther Freilich: Die Frau es hat die Lager, sie hat geschrieben, wann ich kommen. Alle, äh, auf die “gare” [franz. Bahnhof?] mit gefälschten Papieren
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Freilich: [unverständlich]
Esther Freilich: Und ich, ich [unverständlich] ihr gewinnt einen Korb und dazu von viertausend Soldaten
David Boder: Wer hat das behauptet?
Esther Freilich: Ich. Ich bin [unverständlich]
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Freilich: [unverständlich]
David Boder: Und so du bist dann weggekommen?
Esther Freilich: Ja.
David Boder: Wohin?
Esther Freilich: Ich bin nach Hause. Die Mutter mir gekommen mit den Sachen.
David Boder: Aha. Und?
Esther Freilich: Nach zwei Jahren. Ich bin zurückgekommen nach Paris.
David Boder: Aha. Wenn ist die Mutter gekommen suchen? Wenn die Deutschen sind schon weggegangen?
Esther Freilich: Nein. Dazu [unverständlich]
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Freilich: [unverständlich]
Esther Freilich: Ja, ich hab vergessen zu sagen, [unverständlich]
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Freilich: Bin ich gefahren nach [unverständlich]
David Boder: Du bist gefahren nach [unverständlich] mit wem?
Esther Freilich: Ja. Mit die, äh, Mutter, mit dem, äh, mit dem Bruder und mit der Schwester. Die andere...
David Boder: Mit die andere Schwester.
Esther Freilich: Andere Schwester. Mit andere Schwester.
David Boder: Ja, und was hat dort passiert?
Esther Freilich: Da [unverständlich]
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Freilich: Versteht? Den Zug von [unverständlich, klingt wie: „hat man uns da reingemacht...“]
Esther Freilich: Und wir fahren den ganzen Tag und ganze Nacht...ohne zu kennen, äh, ohne sie geben etwas womit man nicht...
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Freilich: [unverständlich]
Esther Freilich: Ich hab [unverständlich]...Ich hatte ein Plastik, äh, platz...sitz.
David Boder: Hmm.
Esther Freilich: [unverständlich] und nachher bin ich raus.
David Boder: In [unverständlich]?
Esther Freilich: Ja.
David Boder: Hmm.
Esther Freilich: Und nachher bin ich raus, bin ich, hab ja weggelaufen von dem Hopital, hab ja nicht gewusst, was [unverständlich]
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Freilich: Viel Glück in dem Tag, da hat man schon wieder rausglaufen, weil, äh, man wollte mich [unverständlich, klingt wie „separieren“].
Esther Freilich: Und ich bin dann weggelaufen. Von der, äh...
David Boder: Und zu wem bist du gelaufen?
Esther Freilich: Zu der Mama.
David Boder: Aha.
Esther Freilich: [unverständlich]
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Freilich: Und, äh, und der Sache. Und wir sind die Nacht rausgegangen, [unverständlich]
David Boder: Ja, man hat das wieder [unverständlich]
Esther Freilich: Ja. Sind wir dann raus und der Tag, ich hab gesehen, wie man deportiert die Schwester...
David Boder: Deine Schwester?
Esther Freilich: Und hat sie gerufen die Neime [gemeint: Namen?], ne?
Esther Freilich: Ich hab gesehen, wie man gerufen die Name, die Schwester weggefahren und hab gesagt, ich geb dir was [unverständlich].
David Boder: Aha.
Esther Freilich: Bin ich gelaufen [unverständlich] und sie getragen. Nachher der Bruder ist wieder raus, hat man gedacht ihn nicht deportieren.
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Freilich: Die Mutter mit anderen Kinder darf deportieren. [unverständlich]
David Boder: Und was machst du jetzt?
Esther Freilich: Ich weiß nicht? Jetzt?
David Boder: Ja.
Esther Freilich: Was ich will machen?
David Boder: Ja. Was?
Esther Freilich: [unverständlich]
David Boder: Ja, aber gehste jetzt zur Schule? Studierst d...
Esther Freilich: Nee, jetzt geh ich zur Schule für D...
David Boder: Ja, aber bevor du kamst, bist du gegangen zur...
Esther Freilich: Die Schule.
David Boder: In welche Schule?
Esther Freilich: Ich bin ge...äh, die [unverständlich]
David Boder: Ja, in der französischen Schule?
Esther Freilich: Ja.
David Boder: Mit französischen Kindern?
David Boder: Und sind sie gut zu, äh, zu dir?
Esther Freilich: Sie sind, also...der eine hat geschrieben, du schmutziger Jude...
David Boder: No. Und der Lehr...wer ist der Lehrer?
Esther Freilich: Der Lehrer hat mir...ein französische Frau hat mir nicht lieb.
David Boder: Warum nicht?
Esther Freilich: Ich weiß nicht. Sie hat nicht lieb jeden.
David Boder: Oh! Wie viele Juden seit ihr in Klass....[unverständlich]
Esther Freilich: In meiner Klasse sind vier Juden [unverständlich]
David Boder: Vier Juden [unverständlich]. Und das hat keiner bemerkt [unverständlich]?
Esther Freilich: Nein.
David Boder: Nu, und, äh, wie lange musst du noch gehen zur Schule?
Esther Freilich: Ein Jahr.
David Boder: Ein Jahr und denn was wirst du tun?
Esther Freilich: Und dann will ich gehen in die andere Schule, deutsche Schule.
David Boder: Was tust du lernen?
Esther Freilich: Ich [unverständlich], ah, was ich gelernt hab? Die Maschine.
David Boder: Was für eine Maschine?
Esther Freilich: Äh, Steno.
David Boder: Oh! Zum Schreiben machst du Maschine?
Esther Freilich: Ja.
David Boder: Nu, das wirst du schon auch lernen.
David Boder: [In English] Alright. This concludes a short [unintelligible]...Freilich, whose mother insisted that the child be interview— [unintelligible]...appeal. And, eh [unintelligible] now all her difficulties at school are due to the fact that she is Jewish. Eh, this is, eh, August the 9th, taken at...number 9 Rue de Patin, the home for aged Jews. The child is a child of a concierge here at the place. And, umm, this concludes the recording...wire recording of Illinois Institute of Technology.